All right, folks, welcome back.
This is our 21st episode of the 2022 free ICT YouTube mentorship.
A little tongue-twisted there.
So we're looking at the hourly chart on the dollar index.
Why are we here?
Why are we looking at this?
Well, I'm looking at this because I want to show you the relationships between a risk
on and risk off market.
If you've been following along in the comment section and if you haven't paid attention
or even noticed all my videos in this mentorship, the comment section is open.
Okay, so you're welcome to make your appreciation known.
You're welcome to prompt me with specific questions that you want to see me kind of
like touch on without making too much of a long-winded request for it.
I can kind of get a feel for what you're looking for and I'll work those ideas into the lessons
that we can hopefully get everybody's understanding on the same page.
I may not respond to your post.
I may not, you know, directly answer you.
Sometimes if it's short and easy, I'll do that.
But if it's a question I see a lot of across the other videos as well, I use the videos
to kind of like answer it.
So it's important for you to take notes because usually you'll find that the questions you
have are answered in the progression through this mentorship if you're coming here later
than 2022.
All right, so one of the questions I got, and I get this a lot for people that have
not been trained by me, the idea of using the dollar index, is it useful like when I
look at the Forex market, like if the dollar's going higher, obviously that's going to put
pressure on the foreign currencies and it'll be less likely for them to have sustained
rallies.
They're more likely to have sustained declines.
So dollar up, foreign currency down.
Dollar down, foreign currency up.
The reason why that's occurring is it's a risk on risk off scenario.
Dollar if it is going up as we have here, this is a risk off scenario.
Okay, risk off scenario implies that generally every other market or asset class will start
to decline and this is treated as like a flight to quality, okay, or a safe haven.
So money pours into the dollar and it pours out of risk assets.
That would be like foreign currency.
That's why I've been telling you to look at the Euro dollar to go lower and make a new
low on its daily chart and today it did it and now it's random and then also this applies
as well to the stock market and index market.
So obviously I'm kind of like pushing the index futures in this mentorship on YouTube
but it's applicable obviously, everything I'm teaching here is universal so it works
in everything.
Now I'm not co-signing crypto as a reminder, I do not trade cryptocurrency.
I have absolutely zero experience trading cryptocurrency outside of a demo account or
a paper trading account.
I've never done anything with it, I've never opened up a crypto account, I have no interest
in ever going into that asset class and there it is, okay.
I see a lot of you asking that in the comment section so I'm going to try to throw this
out there every now and then as a reminder because I don't do anything with an asset
class.
I have a lot of students that trade them and they swear by my concepts working there but
I personally don't do it, okay so there's that.
I am a forex and futures trader so that way you guys can know what my specialty is and
I want to show you this chart here and remind you of what I mentioned in the previous week
in our meetings together in the episodes.
I said that we would likely see the dollar index drop down if I was making the market
for the dollar.
I would see it go down to around 99.92 and you can go back and listen to the videos and
then obviously you'll see it, it's there and hear it.
Then I said I would run the relative equal highs and start to run it higher.
I gave you the objectives of relative equal highs and mentioned like 102, 103 and even
my private mentorship group knows there's objectives as well and we have it here, okay.
So I'll leave it up to you whether or not you find this inspiring or not knowing that
this was likely to occur for a London set up and then rally higher.
I want you to look at the relationship between this price move here and go back in the commentary
where I was referring to that daily bearish order block on the index feature, okay so
I was talking about the low of the daily order block, the open order block and the mean threshold
halfway and then the high of the order block being the less likely level to be traded to
and I'll talk about that when we get into the E-mini S&P portion of this episode but
for now let's take a look at what the relationship looks like with the dollar versus the E-mini
S&P.
So this is the June contract for 2022 of the E-mini S&P futures market and you can see
as the dollar creates its important low that I called publicly, you guys know it, I've
said it, I explained it to you in detail.
As this dollar was going higher, what was going on in the E-mini S&P?
See that inverted relationship there?
That's why I could go back and listen to the recording when I was talking about that bearish
order block on the E-mini S&P, I said that we're going into May and it's usually a seasonal
decline and I'm going to be looking for signatures to warrant downward pressure in this particular
asset class and reaching for those relative equal lows on the daily chart.
Hello, look at your chart folks.
This is what it's like to be a mentor, this is what it's like to know what's likely to
occur with tools that make sense.
There's nothing ambiguous here, there's nothing splattered across the chart, it's just simple
sound logic, okay?
I'm hopefully inspiring you to simplify, which many on the outside looking at what I do will
make snide remarks like, oh, he overcomplicates things and I'm not complicating anything.
These are very simple ideas and it helps you build the idea of bias, it gives you intermarket
relationships and intermarket analysis to give you the trust, okay?
Why did I feel confident to publicly say that 9992 level?
Well, I explained that.
Why did I think it was going to rally from there?
Because I'm bullish on dollar.
Why did I hint that we're going to be going lower into the E-mini S&P relative equal lows
and as we enter into May, that's a seasonal tendency.
So all those factors came together in my experience of almost 30 years was used to hint at something
for you to study and if I'm right or if I'm wrong, you get to be a judge, okay?
You get to see and weigh me in the balances.
I've laid it out there in your hands, you see right now in this chart what I was forecasting,
the reasons why I was doing it, why I said what I said and why it looks like it does
in your chart today.
All right, so here's that daily chart and here's that bearish order block I was referring
to and the high asset is the level we don't look for it to be traded to and you can see
we didn't even get to it there, okay?
So we route up into the order block and then we had the weakness that was expected as we
go into that May month and we're reaching into these relative equal lows.
That's the next draw on liquidity but for now, again, just keep your study inside this
order block that's taught in this YouTube channel, okay?
So while it's not a main factor in the model I'm teaching in the mentorship for YouTube
here, I leaned on that as a basis for my analysis.
Why I felt this was likely to go lower, that's the order block, that's the one that makes
the likelihood of the market turning in this area and then going lower and attacking the
sell side below here, below the relative equal lows here is next and then this low
here.
So ultimately we're looking for a run below here for the sell side.
Now it might want to go down below here and give a little bit of a retracement if it leads
this portion open that might want to rally from going over here up there.
I don't think it would do that personally but it could happen but it's likely to draw
into that old low here.
Now how we trade once we get there, that'll be interesting because I don't know if it's
going to accelerate violently to the downside or if we're going to have a sharp retracement
higher, I don't know that, okay?
I don't care to know that.
Right now I'm just looking for and submitting to the idea that we're going to keep drawing
down on the daily chart.
Each daily candle should be expanding lower and reaching into this area, okay?
That's what I'm expecting, that's my ideal scenario.
Now if you look at the daily range here today, we had a little bit of movement above the
previous day.
So we rallied above Monday's high and then failed and accelerated to the downside.
Fell short of just running below these relative equal lows but I still believe that's where
we're likely to go.
Had a little bit of consolidation in here, dropped and we had a nice rally in here.
Now admittedly, listen closely folks because this is one of those times where I didn't
get it right and I have no problem telling you.
I was expecting this to rally just a little bit higher and maybe flirt with that 43.20
level.
I thought that we could get one more spike up into that and then I was expecting the
rollover and go lower.
That did not happen, okay?
So let's go into the lower time frame, 15 minute time frame.
Here is the midnight hour, New York time, and the opening price there.
Notice we only had one, two little moves above that and that's a really anemic movement for
what I was expecting, a little bit more pronounced rally higher.
I wanted to see a little bit of a judo swing, about 20 handles, 15 handles to that effect
like that and then break down and create something like this, okay, but we didn't get it.
So some of you may be asking and I believe it was Michelle in the comment section mentioned
that it didn't appear that power three was in effect today.
It actually was, but sometimes it's really, really small little movements like this and
it may not be useful to you, but what happens is when you enter the London session which
we do here, at three o'clock in the morning it breaks down relative to New York local
time.
Okay, so 3 a.m. New York local time.
There's a lot of folks in the comment section that are referring to and confused about daylight
savings time and such.
All of that is resolved if you simply just listen to the instruction I gave every single
time I mentioned the time aspect.
If you use this little area down here on TradingView and toggle it to New York and all you do is
by clicking it, a window will pop up, scroll to where it says New York, highlight that
one, click it and then you're set.
You don't have to worry about it.
Don't worry about daylight savings time, don't worry about anything.
As long as you are aware of what local time is in New York, set a clock on your computer
that always tracks the local time in New York, 24, 7, 365 days a year.
If you do that, you'll never have any confusion about what you should be doing relative to
time, okay?
So if you have a small little movement like this, it can throw you off if you're expecting
like I was.
I wanted to see a little bit higher rally.
So in the morning, I was looking for maybe a little poke above here.
Didn't happen.
We broke down, retraced back in.
There's order block and the imbalance and spent a little bit of time here and then rolled
over right before the 930 opening, okay?
And I'm going to talk a little bit about the 830 and the 930, what times are useful, what
are beneficial to your analysis and what you should be concerned about, okay?
Because I know there's a lot of questions about that.
But ultimately, we moved into the lunch hour, had a little bit of retracement here, broke
more and then aggressive selling, really aggressive selling into the PM session, into the close
of the day.
If you look at the opening price at midnight local time, I'm sorry, New York midnight local
time, that's what this here is, that's that opening price.
This price is useful for trading the London session, that's two o'clock and five o'clock
in the morning, New York local time, and it helps me frame the power three for the daily
range.
If I'm bearish, I'm looking for something to rally above that opening price in London.
That's my ideal scenario, I'm looking for that personally.
As you can see, we really didn't get much of that today.
It was extremely heavy and just wilted and went lower.
Sometimes that's going to happen, folks, and in this instance, I missed a setup.
I don't get in what I'm thinking I'm expecting to see.
I'm human, you're human, you're going to look at something in the chart and you're going
to have something that is your favorite model, whatever pattern is you're looking for, and
it may not even be my stuff.
Say you're just here casually watching, you're probably nodding your head saying, yeah, I've
had lots of instances where I was looking for my particular setup and it didn't materialize
and it went the other way without me.
You're going to miss moves, you're going to misinterpret it, you're going to read it wrong.
That's going to happen.
That's why you have to use a stop loss, that's why you have to be controlled about how many
times you go into the marketplace, and you also have to have some measure of flexibility
and that comes with experience.
You're not going to always be able to see that this isn't going to go up for you initially.
It's just going to just wilt and go the other direction.
When we get into the 830 hour, and I have the lines really light here because I want
to be able to show where the highs and the lows were on the respective candles.
This is the 830 and this is the 12 a.m. midnight candle at New York.
This is New York and this is midnight New York, so there's a distinction here.
The beginning of the day, this is where I look for the daily range Power 3 setup and
or the ideal scenario, if I'm bearish, I want to see something rally above that opening
price.
If I'm bullish, I want to see it decline below that opening price.
That's pretty much the basis for the opening price at midnight.
It may not be a factor for you, like it is here, it's not much of a use for anything
except for, well here it opened and it just basically went lower from there.
At 830, the same thing, I look for those types of scenarios.
Now I'm looking for weaker prices, I'm looking for it to trade lower, and does it rally above
the 830 opening price?
It never does.
It's too heavy, it just wilts, it keeps going lower.
Now the opening price at 830, I use that for, again, Power 3 for the New York session.
The same thought process I'm using for the opening price at midnight in New York time,
that opening price, if I'm bearish, I want to see a move above that, that's what I dub,
a Judas swing, a false rally, a suspect rally.
I usually like to fade those types of moves.
As it goes up, I sell right into it.
It's scary for someone that doesn't understand what you're looking at, but if you know what
and it takes a lot of experience and learning and back testing and seeing things, you'll
be able to do those types of things over time.
But that same element of trying to look for a short above that opening price in New York
when I'm bearish, I would expect the same thing to happen for the New York session,
a rally above that opening price at 830, and then decline.
So I'm looking for something to rally above that and fade it, but it isn't doing it today.
So now look what's occurring here.
This is really important that you understand this part of it.
You know that I've been bearish.
I've made it public knowledge here.
Did we rally above the opening price at midnight?
No.
Did we rally above the opening price at 830?
And we're bearish.
What does that indicate to you?
Obviously, with the benefit of hindsight, it's extremely bearish.
It can't even rally to a short term premium above the opening price at key levels and
time.
So we have an extremely heavy bearish market.
So it's not going to give us these stunning little short term rallies that we can fade.
It's just going to stay heavy and either you get in where you can find small little pockets
of imbalance or you miss the move entirely.
Now as it happens today, my wife went on a trip.
I had to take her to the airport.
I was only able to capture $2,000 worth of movement in the S&P e-mini.
That's the only thing I could capture.
When I got back, I didn't participate in the afternoon.
And looking at it now, I missed a really, really huge opportunity.
There was no trading whatsoever in the afternoon.
My money was made short on e-mini S&P in the morning session.
And that's all I had for today.
If I would have just held on to what I had in the morning, I could have done around $12,000
today alone.
But I didn't hold on to it.
I had other things to take care of.
And that's the reality of things.
Real life creeps in.
It's going to happen.
But for those of you that are trying to learn these concepts, these types of movements are
going to be very frustrating in the early stages of your development because you're
going to feel like they're changing something.
You're aware of this.
This stuff goes on a lot.
It happens in the futures markets, like commodities like corn, soybeans, gold, oil, stocks.
Sometimes the markets are just simply too heavy.
And they're not going to rally for you to short into.
It doesn't mean that they've changed anything.
It doesn't mean that the concepts don't work.
It just means that this is a market that is extremely bearish.
And when it's extremely bearish, you have to trade it differently.
And I'll show you what I mean by that here.
And I'm not trying to inspire much outside of the mentorship.
But I know some of you have asked this in the comment section.
Plus, it helps my own personal group to understand this as well.
So it'll be a little bit of a refresher for them.
All right.
So here's the London Open setup.
This was the move that set up the only real sound entry, in my opinion, that took place
today here.
This displacement, fair value gap, rallies up, bearish order block, fair value gap, runs
into it.
And then you hold it.
Because at the market structure, shift below the short-term low, the imbalance, we went
back up in.
This imbalance here, remember what I taught you about this?
This one here can be traded too on a spike.
You can get up in there, but your entry is on the lower fair value gap.
Do you see the logic working here?
You are going to use a stop that's going to allow for the market trading up into this
one.
So you may not like that much risk.
You may not be able to take this trade.
That's all part of this game.
But you can trade a micro.
Or maybe you could.
I shouldn't say that you can.
I don't know what all of your risk parameters are, what you can work with in terms of margin.
But while you're learning in paper trading, obviously, you can use anything because it's
all hypothetical money and you're learning the skill set.
But the rules are still sticking to what I gave you in terms of the logic.
If you have two fair value gaps, you're using this as the entry and you're using this as
the risk.
Don't always assume that you can get up here and get the best entry because it never went
there.
See that?
So it's things like this.
This is what I refer to as a signature in price action.
These are algorithmic things that repeat.
But you have to have the discernment and experience to know when it's likely to occur, when it
isn't likely to occur.
So anyway, let's talk a little bit about the 830 time period and 930.
All right, so here's 830, got the imbalance here.
After 830, normally with the model, I'm teaching you to look for something to the left prior
to 830.
Some kind of short-term high, we want to see it rally up.
And using the opening price at 830, which is here, we want to see it rally above that,
run some stops, then break down and create this type of scenario where it has displacement
and an imbalance.
It rallies back up into the imbalance and sells off.
The model doesn't exist in today's price action on the five-minute chart.
It doesn't give it to you there.
So I'm going to give you coaching, if you will, to kind of show you what was in price
and some of the things I was looking at to help get in sync with the move.
But I didn't ride the whole thing out.
And believe me, I'm looking at this today wishing I just would have had at least one
of the two contracts I had on still and just let it run and I could have done about eight
grand or so.
But I didn't do it.
I was leaving.
I was taking my wife to the airport and it's just better if you're not going to be in front
of the charts and anything can happen, you know, I could get delayed out there, the phone
doesn't connect with the, you know, the broker.
It's just better just to be away.
If you're not going to be paying attention to the marketplace, just simply completely
close the entire position.
Also I'll throw this in here too.
Shortly before I started doing the recording here, I saw a question, do I ever hold overnight
in these current conditions?
I stopped holding overnight like 24 hours years ago.
We had a lot of things going on in the world that changed my trust.
Just like I used to hold things over the weekend and expect continuation going into the opening
on Sunday and Monday, I no longer hold over the weekend.
So I am 100% in a session or a day and out before the close.
Like I'm not holding 24 hours.
I'm not holding 12 hours, you know, I'm not doing those types of positions.
Typically my trade is anywhere between 90 minutes to two hours maximum.
That's about the length of time that I'm holding and I'm looking to take mine and get out and
then reassess things because there's just too much risk right now in the marketplace,
all asset classes and things are now starting to get a little wild and it could get a little
bit more wild.
Okay, but the five minute chart has the imbalance in here.
We saw that run and the model, I want to see it run above the opening price at 830.
The opening price at 830 is the New York Sessions opening price.
Now don't get confused with the New York Midnight Candles opening price because the New York
in the name, New York Session is the 830 to 11 time period, New York local time.
So I'm looking for this framework to offer power three, which is a fractal element of
accumulation, manipulation and distribution.
That's what power three, the three things that is empowering you is understanding those
three elements.
Accumulation, what's accumulating?
Short positions, why?
Because it's bearish.
So smart money would accumulate short positions, then anticipate manipulation above the opening
price.
They would assume more short positions there.
Then it starts to go the other direction and they distribute their short positions at some
important low that we're able to forecast and obviously it's relative to those daily
equal lows and old daily lows and projections with the FIB.
All those ideas come to mind in concert with an agreement as well with time of day.
So we're looking at a movement down into around the lunch hour beginning at noon, it creates
the important low there and we have a retracement during the lunch hour.
One more time it punches above the high here, then it breaks down, consolidates, starts
to create one, two, three and then you can expect continuation going into the afternoon
session.
We're not going to talk about the afternoon session because honestly I wasn't participating
in it and it is what it is.
I'm familiar with this morning because I had some horses in the race today, okay?
So we'll start in a little bit more detail here.
Here we have the four minute chart, the imbalance here.
This is one again that is not rallying above the opening price at 8.30 and it's showing
8.28 but that's because I'm showing a four minute chart so don't let that confuse you
but the opening price again never got traded above at the 8.30 candle.
So whatever that opening price is at 8.30, you extend that out in time and you want to
see that rally above.
Now when you have this expectation, the other aspect of time is the 9.30 opening.
That's when the equity market or stocks themselves start trading their New York session.
So what happens at 9.30?
What am I expecting at 9.30?
Well number one, 9.30 is just when the opening occurs and there's initial volatility.
Now it could be whipsaw where it can go up and down real short term and go both directions
in a small range.
Sometimes it could be a really large range and clear both sides of the buy and sell and
then whatever the real move is going to be for the day, we wait for that to unfold.
Today we can see at 9.30, it just starts to run lower, doesn't give us a rally at all.
So it just starts to speed up what's already in motion from three o'clock in the morning
during the London Open session.
So at 9.30, all it does is just start to accelerate down.
Okay, and the same idea is being shown on a three minute chart.
You can see here that little imbalance gets a little bit more refined, trades up into
it rather handsomely, breaks down and here's another, what a bearish order block.
Now this is one in here where it's useful because you have a little bit more insight
as to what it's doing.
It's too heavy, it's not likely to rally, there's no reason to go long, start looking
for reasons to get short and any time you get an imbalance and we're above those relative
equal lows on the daily chart because it's going to be drawn down into that.
That's the heaviness objective.
Why the prices keep going lower, lower, lower, lower is because they're gravitating towards
those relative equal lows on the daily chart.
So go back to the chart where I mentioned in this video and showed the daily chart,
I have that little blue line, that's where price is being drawn to.
The algorithm is marching every minute, every hour, every day to that level.
How long does it take to get there?
I don't know that, but I mentioned in my group that I didn't want to see it happen like we're
seeing it right now because it's too fast and it doesn't give it a lot of opportunities
to get in with it and ride it.
So you either have to have entries like this, which unfortunately isn't scalable with the
model I've shared publicly, but I do have obviously opportunities to go over it like
this and show you how you can still use the idea of the fair value gap to get in with
it, but you're going to have to leave out the element of a rally above the opening price
at $830 and $930 just creates a lot of volatility.
The initial surge in the New York Session as the stocks begin to trade basically.
So as a recap here before I go into the next slide, midnight New York time, that opening
price, I used that to trade the London Open Session, that's two o'clock to five o'clock
in the morning, and also to help frame the idea like say I sleep through London, which
is 90% of the time what I do today.
Like I don't do a lot of London Session trading and because of that, when I wake up and I'm
looking at the market around seven o'clock in the morning or so, I'm looking at what
has happened overnight and did we create a scenario that I would be looking to trade
if I was awake during London.
If it happens, then I know that I'm really built in with an advantage on the daily bias
because if I'm bearish and it creates a rally above the opening price, midnight time New
York, and it creates that rally, that little Judas swing that I've explained many times
already, and it starts to decline and I'm below that around seven o'clock in the morning,
I know that I'm likely to create a little short-term rally, but it would be above, ideally
above the opening price at $830, but it may not do that and price just remained heavy
below both opening prices at midnight New York local time and $830 New York local time.
So everything was extremely bearish and it was just so heavy, it could not mount any
meaningful rallies.
Many times in my early development, I got crushed on days like this where it felt like
okay it's too low now, it can't just keep going lower, so I'm going to try to buy it
now, because indicators told me that we're oversold, 1992, 1993, 1994, I blew account
after account after account doing that and it's frustrating.
Now obviously with three decades of experience behind me, I know what it's trying to do and
where it's trying to get to and it's getting there in a really fast rate of speed.
Now obviously you can get there a lot faster than that, but I don't want to do that because
it gives no real opportunity for me to engage and participate in and it doesn't give you
as the student to engage also with your demo or paper trading account to practice.
But as real life sometimes is, it's unfair, okay, it doesn't give us what we want, sometimes
our expectations and our wants are denied and in today's climate that is not popular.
That's why this market and trading these markets is very, very difficult, especially for like
the Millennials, okay.
That ideal perfect always come exactly as I expected, sometimes it's denied and either
you accept that and navigate the markets within perfection and without the ideal scenario
for your model or you're comfortable with just letting go and not doing anything and
being accepting when it comes to big moves and you can't participate in it.
There's lots of moves folks over the last 30 years that I missed that were huge, big,
huge moves.
For instance, Bitcoin, I called that thing, I called that thing at 7,500 to 20,000 and
then right before 20,000 I said it wasn't going to 20,000, it was 19,700 and I said
it's going to go to 6,000 and everybody laughed and went down and I said I was going to go
down to 3,000 but it went down to like 32 and then I think a couple times I had it wrong
and then I said that we would go to 20,000 by Christmas, I think it was 2020 and then
I said 30,000 by New Year's and I was off by about 18 hours, it went to 30,000 on the
second I believe it was on January 2021 and then I said 55,000 and 66,000 that was about
as far as I could see it go and we went just a little bit above 66,000 and hasn't been
doing much since but I didn't do anything with that with real money so I missed a huge
run in something that would have otherwise paid a lot of money and I've missed a lot
of moves in the futures markets and a lot of commodities, I missed a lot of stock moves
you know while I was teaching Forex, there's a lot of stock movement and index futures
that I didn't participate in, guess what, it's okay I'm able to still find trades, I'm
not starving and that's the reality, you're going to have to come to terms and to grip
with you have no way of participating in every single move and don't think that you're going
to find every big move, you're not going to participate in every single price swing, you're
not going to folks, I miss moves, you're going to miss moves and it's okay, it's part of
this game, this business is going to still run and do the same things we're looking for
all the time and you're not going to participate in every move okay, so give yourself the permission
okay to be human, you're going to do it wrong sometimes, you're going to see it for something
it's not and you're going to miss that big move, I had a little piece of this today but
I didn't get the whole thing, I wish I would have but I didn't and it's okay, I forgive
myself for being a good husband and taking my wife to the airport, I know this is all
too much stuff and you don't care, some of you like to say those things in the comments,
get to the point, the point is you do this, you're going to have these elements creep
in and how are you going to deal with it, you're going to get mad and go on the social
media and you know blur it out and curse and say these markets suck, no that's not
what you should be doing, you should just reason with yourself ahead of time, say okay
I'm not going to be able to do everything, I'm not going to participate in every single
move and this is what happens sometimes, it doesn't mean the model is broken, I promise
you and over the next couple of weeks you're going to see the model delivering like it's
done in the past and it's fine, there's going to be times when the market shifts in and
out and the market structure is just too overwhelmingly bullish or too overwhelmingly bearish, in
this instance the bearishness I gave you guys just was a lot more bearish than the model
would permit for entry but you can see there's fair day gaps in here you can use to participate,
dropping down to two minute chart, let's see again, we find in real nice here and then
once more in here and then drop down into that noon time, creating an important low
which is what I taught you in this mentorship already and that two minute imbalance you
can see on the one minute chart here and here, really nice delivery there and these are just
simple little imbalances to get in sync with what is already in motion, not needing to
see it rally above the 830 opening price because it's not likely to so it takes a little
bit of courage to get in here and trade these types of setups but that's what you do or
you don't do anything and you just tape read, you watch it when it does it and say okay
I would like to see it drop here and does it drop, yes and you study that and you get
another fair day gap in here that's not highlighted and it rallies up to a fair shorter buck and
your stop is above here and just because it goes down lower doesn't mean jam your stop
loss to here because that's what happens, you need to have time and price behind you
before you start moving your stop loss and alternate trades obviously lower into that
noon time.
Alright so I think that's going to be it, the next episode on Thursday I'm going to
show you a couple things inside the trading platform on TradingView that I think are useful,
that answers a few things and one of those students made mention that could I literally
go in and show how to set up the Fibonacci so I thought it was kind of simple already
but obviously some of you are really really new and you're not familiar with the TradingView
platform so I'm going to add that at the end of the video on Thursday coming up okay so
that way it's at the end and anybody that already knows how to do it they don't have
to go through and watch all that stuff but I'll give you another teaching and lesson
obviously on Thursday and until I talk to you then be safe.